the reality is that most people don't
change most people live the same 6
months a 100 times in a row and then
they die they go to the same places they
make the same jokes they have the same
Small Talk they work the same job and
then they die because they were never
willing to be uncomfortable because they
were never willing to change and a lot
of people get real uncomfortable when I
talk about this stuff but most people
are average and most people stay stuck
in the same patterns they live the same
6 months for 40 straight years and never
change and so if you want to be
exceptional then you will often have to
be the exception